hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of modeling the masters
I believe that the best and fastest way
to grow business is to model the
strategies of people who already done
what you're trying to do so today we're
gonna look at how former brick mason
refused to settle for less and he felt
he deserved and went out to build were
the most successful financial companies
in the world this is the story of Visa
founder D hock and the top three lessons
that you can learn from his success
d hock is the founder and former CEO of
Visa in 1968 when credit cards were
first starting to get popular Hauk
convinced the Bank of America to release
control over the BankAmericard credit
card program he started a new company to
control the credit cards it was called
National Bank America and later changed
to visa hock came from a modest
household his father was a utility
lineman and after marrying his high
school sweetheart
Hawks first jobs were working in the
slaughterhouse and for brick mason he
became interested in the banking world
and walked away from three separate jobs
at respected financial companies because
he thought that they were too
hierarchical and controlling which
limited his creativity hock went looking
for an opportunity to build a different
type of organization one that valued the
creativity and enthusiasm of its
employees the result of this plan was
visa today Visa has over eight billion
dollars in revenues and processes over
60 billion transactions per year by
refusing to settle for less than he felt
he deserved Hawk was able to build one
of the most successful brands in the
world and a company that he could be
proud of to help you get what you
deserve
here are three action items that you can
take away from V Hawk
action item number one hire people
different from you we all like to stay
in our comfort zones and many
entrepreneurs make the mistake of hiring
people who are exactly like them if
you're great at sales you don't want to
hire all salespeople or your company
won't have any organizational structure
if you're great at programming you don't
want to hire all programmers or there
won't be anybody to promote your product
successful entrepreneurs realize what
they're good at and what they need help
with and surround themselves with the
people who best complement their
strengths and weaknesses here's what Dee
Hawk had to say about hiring and
managing people never hire or promote in
your own image it is foolish to
replicate your strengths it is idiotic
to replicate your weakness is essential
to employ trust and reward those whose
perspective ability and judgment are
radically different from yours it is
also rare for requires uncommon humility
tolerance and wisdom hire and promote
first on the basis of integrity second
motivation third capacity fourth
understanding fifth knowledge and last
and least experience without integrity
motivation is dangerous without
motivation capacity is impotent without
capacity understanding is limited
without understanding knowledge is
meaningless without knowledge experience
is blind experience is easy to provide
and quickly put to use by people with
all the other qualities money motivates
neither the best people nor the best in
people it can move the body and
influence the mind but it cannot touch
the heart or move the spirit that is
reserved for belief principle and
morality as apollyon observed no amount
of money will induce someone to lay down
their life but they will gladly do so
for a bit of yellow ribbon action atom
number two be a leader as soon as you
start building a team they're going to
start looking at you as their leader
they'll not only look at what decisions
you make but also the process you go
through to make those decisions they're
going to want to see someone who they
can respect and learn from your
leadership skills might be weak right
now
but you'll need to start improving them
as soon as possible if you want to build
a successful organization here Rd hawks
thoughts on leadership here is a very
heart and soul of the matter if you look
to lead invest at least 40% of your time
managing yourself your ethics character
principal purpose motivation and conduct
invest at least 30% managing those with
authority over you and 15% managing your
peers use the remainder to induce those
you work for to understand and practice
a theory think back to the best boss you
ever had and the worst boss you ever had
make a list of all things done to you
that you abort don't do them to others
ever make another list of things done
for you that you loved do them for
others always people are not things to
be manipulated labeled boxed bought and
sold above all else they are not human
resource they are entire human beings
containing the whole of the evolving
universe limitless until we start
limiting them we must examine the
concept of leading and following with
new eyes we must examine the concept of
superior and subordinate with increasing
skepticism we must examine the concept
of management and labor with new beliefs
and we must examine the nature of
organizations that demand such
distinctions with an entirely different
consciousness action atom number 3
empty your mind many entrepreneurs have
a hard time focusing we're simply doing
too much and never get the chance to
empty our minds of the day-to-day to
focus on the big picture and where our
businesses are going creative ideas
can't be forced and if you want more of
them you'll need to free up your mental
energy so you can focus more than just
being a businessman DeHoff considered
himself a theorist enjoy playing with
ideas more than spreadsheets with
concepts more than numbers despite a
successful career in the financial
industry Hawk was also an active
theorist spending his free time
developing new forms of social and
business organization who's with D Hawk
thinks about emptying your mind
the problem is never how to get new
innovative thoughts into your mind but
how to get old ones out every mind is a
room packed with archaic furniture you
must get the old furniture on what you
know think and believe out before
anything new can get in make an empty
space in any corner of your mind and
creativity will instantly fill it so
remember hire people who are different
than you be a leader and empty your mind
to finish this video I wanted to share
one of my favorite true stories about
d-hop is all of his best quotes after
building the company he felt proud of
hoc resigned from visa in 1984 and spent
almost 10 years farming a 200 acre plot
of land in California isolated from the
business world he used the time to think
about corporate life and how companies
should be run according to hawk
I left Weezer in 1984 because I had
proved everything I had set out to prove
about the effectiveness of these
concepts of organization when visa
became so extraordinarily successful I
thought the world would beat a path to
our door to explore the concepts but it
largely ignored us
it was so different people couldn't
quite understand it there was no stock
so it didn't fit normal business model I
decided I wanted to return to nature and
seclusion and try to develop these ideas
further so I bought 200 acres of ravaged
land in a tiny isolated community on the
coast of California built the house with
a library of four or five thousand bucks
and spent ten years in manual labor or
storing the land to health and beauty
and studying incessantly trying to
develop these ideas I wanted to see if
they were applicable to other
organizations and industries or merely
unique to the banking and credit cards
thank you for joining me for another
edition of Montana masters if you
enjoyed the video please give it a
thumbs up
I'd also love to hear your thoughts or
feedback if you want to leave a comment
below and stay tuned for the next
episode